vous
ouais
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en contournant fuite le pays d'auge et
m'a dit tu connais pas remises en furie
dans les médias ont tout fait pour elle
demande pourrait couper en quatre rémy
vigneaux taurines qui est à venir
two door helsinki et là au bonus
je sors tu es seul tu veux bien que
cette imprudence c'est le cran yakham va
il ne m'a jamais pourquoi il put aussi
rechercher un miroir et une amende aux
indes miroir à le rentrer dans le top 10
je ne peux pas vivre sans miroir
il faut que je me vois la tête aux pieds
pour m'habiller
je rentrerai dans ma potiche quand j'en
aurai un bon c'est un ultimatum
tu l'auras ton miroir parle de lion plat
en miroir on sait bien venue de
touristes pour vous en trouvez en héros
ou à maître malka bon on vous tendez
bien ce trésor de la 3g un besoin de mes
services à des voix un miroir la dgda au
miroir c'est à dire le glass ronde car l
ovale eux alors foule toi même
il ya un peu de désordre je n'ai pas
enfin le ménage depuis quelques jours un
fouillis là dedans
voilà on sent tout petit miroir vous
n'avez rien de plus grand je peux tout
de même pas les voir la galerie des
glaces sommet touche exclusivement
conviendra pas c'est tout même notre mal
qu'un de 9 à vouloir mosca il a
peut-être ce que tu cherches une bonne
idée mais on est une semence khz
antilles
on croit ya qu'à vous est superbe et oui
c'est magnifique mais aller bosser mois
encore dans le dos c'est ça une petite
poussière
voilà après jean si le grand yaka veut
choisir le collier d'aujourd'hui
celui-ci non horrible le bg les déjà
porté à voter les jette le masque a
alors peut-être que celui-ci abominable
nous nous y mettons petit neveu des
pires plus grosse vache tu toi tais toi
méfiance de consentement ne fait pas de
bruit
le crew yaka est très occupé de moi mon
score ya lamiroy quand on voudrait
emporté les tulipes h par titus chez le
miroir du grand yaka font également le
faut mais tu es fou voyons tu ne l'aura
jamais jusqu'à un mois alors jamais des
voix lavalin grande ya un moment tu es
mon plan je veux mettre celui-ci allait
à deux mois mosca et puis c'est qui
c'est quoi faire craquer il faut tirer
doucement si tu casses et ce collier tu
auras vais coup de bâton tuân thermostat
et où j'ai grandi à cacher tellement
graille a qu'un et il est accroché un
autre nom de pêche toi mosca mais je
veux me regarder dans ma mémoire me
voila voila cardiaque
je le tiens je vais être splendide c'est
que je suis si beau mois jusqu'à ce
qu'un oui oui y'a qu'à ou ou messi c'est
incroyable je suis sûr que c'est une
astuce de titus n'est ce pas
jusqu'à ce miroir de doit être regarde
c'est une injure pour le gagna ko grogne
ak c'est affreux j'ai nommé belloy le le
le et oui oui y'a qu'à je l'enlève je
l'enlève ticket ni les miroirs ben
monsieur samoa le gras n'y a qu'à moi
qui suis le plus beau tu as gagné titus
tuer le rad l'astuce le miroir d'une
grande yaka tous trois en compte mon cas
il n'est pas des raids me refaire h ce
titus il réussit à me donner fois dans
le tour et après à près de nantes les
douanes